eurostar snaking its way out of london
today
we are accustomed to the ease of travel
between the uk and europe
but now suddenly many of those links are
being closed
it was the dutch who acted first banning
flights from the uk
just hours after boris johnson had
introduced
tougher new restrictions on many parts
of the country
and revealing the gravity of a new
variant of the coronavirus
and where the netherlands led others
have followed
belgium came next curtailing air and
rail links
that mutation could be an additional
problem scientists today are not quite
sure what the impact could be so i think
we should be careful
once we have more information we'll see
if we should extend or extend that
measure
but right now you can't be too careful
and in the wake of that announcement a
rush for christmas travelers to change
plans
so they could get back to britain before
the ban took effect
it's just everything changing at last
minute is so frustrating because you
it's just honestly i feel like i'm just
tired of it but
you know i'm lucky to be able to go home
i'm going back to my fiance
so i
had to study in belgium for a few months
so i was here but then yeah trying to
get back
as soon as possible now my colleague
texas saying that they changed the rules
the prime minister had announced the
change
and i i checked the website it was no
trains i checked in 10 minutes later
got a train so i've not seen my mum
since january
capacity on the service back to london
was increased today
so more people could get home before
trains stop
running and it isn't just belgium that
has responded
as the day progressed more and more
countries cut their travel links with
the uk
all european governments watch the prime
minister's address
and as they listen to the impact of this
new variant of covid
they reacted with fear italy was the
next to impose restrictions
but the list is growing these bans will
be revised over the coming days
nobody knows how long they'll last but
for the moment continental europe
is wary and turning a cold shoulder
to visitors from the uk adam parsons sky
news
brussels